and II root came into youth ministry
just because he was so charismatic every
to work with the kids at both his home
church and then into the young life and
you might not even guess this he was
also then a gang outreach worker in Los
Angeles moved along with his passion for
ministering to youth and went to full of
seminary for an education and got his
empted off to Princeton seminary for PhD
and now teaches at Luther Seminary as
you know he has had a passion that you
can see from his publications the
promise of despair and the children of a
horse and relationships unfiltered and
but more particularly in the theological
turning youth ministry they use the
Ministry of course as these gifts and
skills about gathering community and
drawing community and being in
relationship but it actually has a
larger purpose and a larger purpose
includes to love our young people in the
name of Christ and to disciple and he
has been purging an argument for a
deeper theological understanding of why
we must reach not just get the numbers
up and keep them out of trouble but
we're going to hear much more about that
today it is really a great privilege
presently kicking this program off with
dr. Andrew
well it is absolutely a pleasure to be
here and I'm very thankful that you all
came and so what I'm gonna do is I'm
just gonna dive in and the hardest thing
for me is gonna be to stay within fifty
five minutes so you can all pray for me
I would appreciate that but I have a few
video clips I want to show you towards
the end and I tell my own students that
you live by the video clip you die by
the video clip yeah so stay for that if
you're thinking I gotta go to a meeting
there's gonna be TV coming so you may
want to stick around so let me tell you
how I got into thinking about this topic
of relationships and youth ministry what
had happened is I skip and mention went
to seminary in Southern California which
is something like a great idea after
growing up in Minneapolis so I moved to
Southern California and what had
happened is this Presbyterian Church one
Wednesday night before I had ever gotten
there but just one Wednesday night
literally 15 kids showed up on the
church steps now this is La that doesn't
happen anywhere in the country but for
sure doesn't happen in Los Angeles and
these kids just literally showed up in
the church steps now why they were there
they're not really sure I mean hopefully
there was the work of the Spirit
involved here but there was also pizza
coming out the windows and truth be told
this the stairs were perfect to
skateboard on so they had showed up the
skateboard on these stairs but the
church to its credit saw this to
serendipitous saw this is an opportunity
for ministry so they looked around to
hire somebody somebody to bridge this
classic youth ministry that was going on
in the church basement and these kids
from the neighborhood that it showed up
on the church steps and what you need to
know about this congregation is if
you've ever been to Glendale California
the 134 freeway cuts right through it in
north of the 134 freeway our foothills
and houses where people are in the film
industry or the computer business who
lived there houses range you know from
half a million dollars to a million and
a half dollars south of the 134 freeway
is kind of the Commerce of Glendale we
called it the flats there are a
Starbucks on every other block Jamba
Juice everywhere the Glendale Galleria
is there and then the church was located
there the church had never kind of
realized that the people who went to the
church now drove in from the foothills
well these kids these 15 kids that
showed up came from bungalows and
apartments in the neighborhood so you
had these neighborhood kids and then
this classic youth ministry so the
church decided they want to do ministry
so they threw money at the problem and
they hired
now I got the job because I could speak
this language in the language I could
speak was a language of relational
ministry I had just come out of staff
for young life and if you know anything
about young life this evangelical
parachurch ministry
it's that relationships are central that
building relationships and young people
are central to it they even call this
incarnation all that we incarnate our
lives of the young people's and so I had
I had done this I could speak the
language I got the job I started it took
me about two days to realize I had no
idea what I was good now I was one of
the best most well-educated best-looking
youth workers I knew of so I figured
yeah I'll just jump in and do this thing
but the team that I was working with we
felt like absolute failures I mean we
had been told that young people wanted a
relationship with an adult if you could
just build this relationship that you
could use this relationship to do really
significant things in their life like
get them to go to church or get them to
see the importance of Jesus in their
life or get them to act in a moral way I
mean that you could be an agent of real
change in their life you could use the
relationship to do that and so we tried
so I would meet a kid on there just
those are my youth minister gurus that
told me that I went into their
environment to their school to their
adolescent hangout place and I would
come up to them and say hey how you
doing and Mark this big six five ninth
grader would look at me and say get the
F out of my face
no Doug fields book ever told me what
you do what's the response to this and
so I would you know I would do this and
how do you do ministry with a group of
kids who refuse your relational contact
but continue to ask for because they
would show up on a Wednesday night when
we'd have our program at 3:00 and state
so 11:30 but wanted nothing to do with
this what do you do with a group of kids
when you finally convince them to let
you take them out for a burger and a
coke and when you drive them back into
their neighborhood the fog that has come
onto your windows they write rival gang
signs on it so when you drop them off
and drive back through the neighborhood
your life is in peril and when you
confront them on this they just think
that was a really funny prank
you know what do you do well it's
actually in the middle of a fight with
my wife that things became clear now
this joke never works but things always
become clear and fights with my wife
that it's my fault
so your that thank you for the courtesy
laughs I appreciate that most you are
thinking what a jerk so my wife and I
were newly married and we were she was
going through a crisis in her family of
origin things were changing and some
pretty difficult things that happened so
we would spend late nights up talking
about issues and frustrations and and
heartbreaks that had occurred and as a
new husband I figured it was my job to
fix every problem that she had so she
would say I'm so angry at this person I
can't believe they've done this I'm just
I could just scream it don't think about
it like that you know I know that's it's
hard but let's think about it like this
and you know she'd give me a look and
then she would have another issue and I
try to fix this one and I continued to
try to fix her issues until finally she
absolutely had enough of me and she gave
me this look that could kill and then
she said these words she said stop stop
trying to fix me and then she said these
incredibly transformational words she
says don't you know relationships aren't
about fixing each other stop trying to
fix me and just be with me and if you
can't be with me nothing can get fixed
anyhow so just stop in being with me
very quickly I realized that's exactly
what I was doing in my ministry that I
was using my relationships to fix these
kids and these kids were from pretty
rough neighborhoods and they knew when
someone was on the hustle and the truth
be told I was on the hustle I was using
my relationships to get somewhere some
are good but I was essentially using the
relationship to get somewhere else so it
led me into this journey of thinking
well what's the point of our
relationships in youth ministry and if
there's something I think that we
probably all share we can talk about
this as we go but that we kind of think
that part of the point of youth ministry
is building relationships with young
people that relationships are essential
piece of it and you usually want a solo
pastor or your lead pastor to be able to
preach and maybe the associate pastor to
be able to do some pastoral counseling
or something but usually when it comes
to the youth worker or the youth pastor
the youth director that person needs to
build relationships with young people
but what are we actually talking about
when we use this language of
relationships with young people now I'm
gonna do something really ruined is what
I'm going to throw a question up I'm
gonna ask you to talk just for a second
together but we have limited time so I'm
going to cut you off so if you're
somebody
has to talk you're gonna have to
bulldoze the person you're talking to so
hopefully you're sitting next to an
introvert if that's you like but here's
the question okay and I'm gonna cut you
up you have about 45 seconds to a minute
to answer this question and the question
is this why of relationships been such
an important piece of youth ministry how
would you answer this question if you're
one of those people that has to
deconstruct the question you can
deconstruct it you're free to do that
but why have relationships was such an
important piece of youth ministry all
right turn to somebody who looks
friendly next to you that you want to
talk to and this is the time if you're a
severe introvert you leave
all right so I'm gonna cut you off sorry
you can pick up the conversation later
but um maybe just two responses to the
things you talked about how would you
answer this question maybe just two
people live relationships in such an
important piece of youth ministry yeah
it has something to do with modeling
witnessing to a relational God maybe
yeah I think that's true I mean we could
make an argument that maybe we're in a
cultural context where young people
don't just de facto trust adults or just
trust people in their lives so it's
tended to see in youth ministry not only
do we want this to witness to a
relationship with God but one of the
ways for them even to give us any time
to listen is to build a relationship now
here's the stupid statement the
stupidest statement you'll hear all day
hopefully here it is the world has
changed a lot in the last 200 years
thank you very much
it was a free lunch I guess it was worth
it but all right so here we go let me
let me rewind 200 years and just make
that case it used to be that the family
was a hermetically sealed unit that in
other words everything you would need to
survive for the most part happened
within the family and we should be too
nostalgic about this this could be
really harsh maybe have you hated your
family or your family was suffering
certain depression and things like that
it can be very difficult but for the
most part everything you need it
happened within your family your basic
needs were met within your family your
relatives were very close by your
religious education would first and
foremost happen at home I mean the early
Protestant Reformation and Luther small
catechism we often forget this but this
was originally written not for the
village pastor only secondarily from the
village bastard it was first and
foremost written for father and mother
to take child on knee into catechized
them at home so you would learn your
basic religious education at home we are
especially in the youth ministry world
we are worlds away from that most
parents in our congregation feel like I
don't know what I would say to my kid
we're paying you I mean we're putting
money in the offering plate for you to
do that and we're kind of at the first
time in the history of the church where
we have a congregation in fan
inside a congregation who feel like it's
not their responsibility to pass some
faith to their children it's your
responsibility as a specialist what they
say is oh my gosh well you went to this
thing at Yale Divinity School and what
would I do you know what to do you're
the specialist and do this but this is a
really new historical phenomenon
education would happen inside the home
some of us were actually raised on the
historical documentary Little House on
the Prairie I'm still freaked out about
the Halloween episode I just yeah when I
saw it when I was 8 it still freaks me
out I remember a little out in the
Prairie when I was watching and growing
up I was always shocked because I was a
kid going to a high school of you know
2,000 students I was always blown away
by the one-room schoolhouse and the most
fascinating thing was that you would
have an eight-year-old and then like a
15 year old that were taking classes
together and then usually the
eight-year-old could read at a level
that the fifteen-year-old could and
there are some legitimate historical
reasons for that one the
fifteen-year-old is probably needed at
home to work the farm or to do a harvest
and the eight-year-old was free to go to
school because after all human muscle
was needed more than human human brain
at this time but also that
eight-year-old probably learned to read
and write add and subtract at home where
the fifteen-year-old didn't have that I
mean your basic building blocks for
education happened at home your
recreational life happened there and
then the family really was an economic
unit you couldn't wake up in the morning
and think I hate my family well a lot of
people woke up and said I hate my family
well you couldn't say I hate my family
I'm moving to LA and becoming an actor
no one could do that I mean you were
dependent on these people to survive
hate them or love them you needed these
people and you were stuck with them now
fast word through industrialization and
into our own time and all these circles
have fallen apart and they have become
what the American sociologist Peter
Berger calls the pluralization of life
worlds now what Berger means is that now
each one of these worlds becomes a world
unto itself with its own practices its
own ideologies and for our narrative
here about relationships its own
intimate connections and relationships
become significant in that it becomes a
world unto itself Berger asserts so to
such an extent that you can imagine this
that everyone has breakfast together in
the morning and when they finish in this
period they all go off to do their own
things for instance kids finish they go
off to a government institution to get
educated dad particularly goes off to a
corporation to go to work and early on
in this period mom
gets up and doesn't work the family's
basic needs what actually goes and buys
them and what happens is what's going on
in these different worlds is not
transferable to the others in other
words parents have no idea what's going
on in this government an institution
called school and you know kids have no
idea what's going on with their parents
at work and he goes to such an extent
that the way that dad treats his
employees at work cannot be the same way
he treats his children so he can't come
home from work and think man I would
really like to upgrade to HBO some great
new shows coming out but I'm seeing
we're paying Suze about 80 to 90 dollars
a month and allowance Suzy come here
Suzy we've loved having you this family
you have offered so much to us things
just aren't really working out we're
gonna have to let you go I mean dad
cannot treat his children the same way
he treats his employees that they're
they're completely different logics
they're completely different ways of
functioning and so we become these
people who have to bounce in and out of
these worlds so when I talk to youth
workers one of the things that they
often complain about if we were playing
family feud and like top three things
Youth orders complain about pretty close
to the top is this statement and I'm
sure you people don't say it but other
people other youth workers say it they
say the problem with our kids is they
act one way at church in another way at
school anyone ever said that or heard
things that they you know they act one
way a church in another way at school
and we act as if that's an adolescent
problem
their parents do the exact same thing
they act one way at work in another way
at church in another way at their
recreational activity and another way
with their buddies they go to a bar with
I mean this is what modernity does to us
it forces us to bounce in and out of
these worlds and you actually are more
successful the more kind of different
selves you can take on in these and
mobilize these for yourself so
adolescence becomes this time of
figuring out when you're in it
particularly this education sphere or
this friendship sphere who you are and
how to function in those now it's no
wonder then in the context of youth
ministry that particularly after the
1950s into the 60s and 70s we start to
use this word relational ministry
because you never talk about relational
ministry in this world it would be
redundant why would you you're given
these relationships you actually hate
these people but you're stuck with them
in relationship this world now you're an
individual and you bounce in and out of
these worlds and in each each of those
worlds you have to figure out who's
friend or foe who's somebody to
connected with who's not so a lot of
your world becomes negotiating these
relationships as you bounce in and out
of these worlds and let me push this
just a little bit further
anthropologists seem to tell us that all
cultures across time and space seem to
have these five broad categories to them
very broad but there's something called
family something called society
something called government something
called economy in something called
religion now they can be radically
different across time and space but
there seems to be something like these
broad categories for instance you can
just think of ancient Hebrew family and
Victorian English family radically
different conceptions of family just
polygamy monogamy or radically different
conceptions but there's still this broad
category called family now if we were to
imagine these like the continents in
continental plates the bigger they were
the more cultural esteem they had if we
were in the heyday which I think was the
the wrong the wrong nostalgic assertion
but we kind of imagined at least some of
us in mainline denominations imagined in
the 1950s everything was ok you know if
we could just kind of turn back the
clock to the 1950s everything was ok
forget all the sexism and racism and all
that stuff but if people went to church
I mean that was good right I mean we
kind of have this nostalgic illusion
that everything was ok in the 1950s but
the truth be told maybe if you were to
give these value the bigger they were
the more cultural value that they had
maybe in the middle of 20th century they
look at something like this family was
huge
religion was huge the economy at its
place society at its place in government
at its place but the two kind of driving
cultural spheres were really family and
religion in this cultural context you
never had to convince a parent why they
should send their kid to confirmation
instead of to football practice on
Wednesday night or why they had to be a
confirmation instead of piano lessons or
tutoring I mean you're just going this
is the way it was gonna be we did this
thing these were kind of driving
cultural realities now if you
fast-forward to our time I think these
things have radically shifted and they
look something more like this now if you
can see that that economy is huge
society's huge the family has shrunk a
great deal government depending on your
politics has got a little bit bigger a
little bit smaller and religion is
shrunk a great deal it doesn't mean
people are no longer religious but it
doesn't seem to organize their lives
like maybe at once dead now if there's a
second thing that youth workers always
complain about the first one is our kids
act one way a church in another way at
school the second thing is something
like this parents are the spawn of the
devil have you ever said it
and usually what that all goes back to
is this very fact what they'll say to me
is they'll say ah my parents might
search they just don't help me out I
mean I'm working so hard and they will
send their kids to volleyball they will
send their kids to language camp I get
called a letter says oh my daughter
can't come to confirmation for six
months because she just got the lead in
the play
why don't want why don't why don't
parents help us out why don't parents
get us to church why don't parents see a
value in church when they send them all
these other things and what I try to
reframe for these youth workers you
people already know that but what I try
to reframe for these youth workers is
that actually I don't think they're the
spawn of the devil
I think they choose to send their kids
to piano they choose to send their kids
to SAT prep instead of Church because
this is gonna be shocking because they
love them and what they had what they've
done is they tacitly I mean it's not
necessarily cognitive but in the back of
their minds they know this is the
culture and is it hot as hard as this
for us church people to come to grips
with it maybe we should really grieve
this learning a second language knowing
how to play a musical instrument being
on a AAU travelling basketball team
holds way more cultural esteem than
being confirmed or being a youth group
member it doesn't hold any cultural
steam in this world it maybe did more so
you don't have to convince parents but
here
well why because if your kid can be on
an AAU basketball team or your kid knows
a second language she can put that on
her college transcript if she gets to
put that on her college transcript
she'll get into a good school if she
gets into a good school she'll have
societal esteem and she'll get a good
education and then she'll be able to go
get a good job and compete in a very
competitive economy so I think they make
these decisions because they actually
love their kids
so Raleigh Martins is gonna be here next
then Raleigh's a good friend of mine and
so I'm gonna hope he may tell a story I
may not but I'm gonna steal this story
from him when you meet Raleigh and you
should come back to hear Raleigh because
Raleigh put this guy he's almost 70 any
he's so energetic I can't keep up with
him but Raleigh is this kind of guy who
loves to talk to anyone so watch out if
you're having lunch because he will talk
your ear off but so when I get onto an
airplane I put every sign up that says
do not talk to me I don't want to look
at you I don't want to have anything to
do with you ever
nonverbal I can put up I do that Raleigh
gets under when airplanes like shaking
people saying it's a colony so he's
sitting next to this businessman on in
on an airplane and of course Raleigh
tourism and says so what do you do and
they're talking with Bob Loblaw and
Raleigh of course will talk to anyone
about anything so he says so do you go
to church
he's a theological educator so he thinks
this is a relevant question so the guy
gives him this look and he says you know
it's funny it's funny that you would ask
me that question he says just last week
we had a family meeting and I've three
kids all ranging from you know high
school down into junior high age this is
what this businessman is saying and he
says that we just realized we were way
too busy like our family we were just
incredibly busy so we decided that we're
gonna have a family meeting and we put
everything that we were doing
cheerleading tutoring everything we were
doing we put it on a white board and he
said we decided as a family we were
cutting 40% just cutting it up so we
went through this process and he says
you know funny thing is church got cut
we decided for this year we're just not
going to church couldn't cut tutoring
couldn't cut violin couldn't cut drama
but cut church well I mean what they're
reading you can just say this guy's a
bad guy this guy's you know he's given
up everything well what he's red red is
this and as hard as it is for us to face
this is more the cultural reality now
why this really matters for our
narrative about relationships and youth
ministry it's because again when this is
the operative cultural reality guess
what you get when religion and family
are the fundamental kind of driving
cultural realities you get relationship
whether you like it or you hate it
actually in the language of the early
20th century late 19th century social
theorists for an Antoninus where he
wrote this book Gemeinschaft
gesellschaft which just let that go over
i know when you say a german word after
lunch people get really tired any up but
what he basically said it the way this
functions is this is this functions in a
situation where you are actually asked
to subordinate your own individual well
to the good of the group in this
cultural context it actually works the
exact opposite economy a society only
work if you
or individual pursuits are more
important than everyone sells this is
built on competition this is built on
you becoming the best and just think
about how that changes parenting style
parents here I don't care what you want
to do you're gonna do this this is what
this family does here as a parent and I
think of this with my children we're
only four and seven my job as a parent
has helped them to become an individual
person who is strong enough to grab
their life for themselves my job isn't
to get them to assimilate to some kind
of relational community my job is to
help them become individuals who are
strong who can be all they can be and
we'll talk about this a little bit with
students this afternoon but this changes
because now this where you were you
would never talk about relational
ministry here why would you it'd be
redundant you're given relationships
there's really no need for youth
ministry in this kind of functional
society
I mean you are bound within this
community you know yourself within it
it's no wonder of that youth ministry
comes around and for even this rhetoric
of relational ministry really comes to
the forefront when this culture starts
to become mobilized because now you go
into this big government institution
called the high school and who is your
friend and who is your foe who do you
who do you date and who don't you I mean
this was really set terms for good or
for ill by your tradition by your
community they told you who you would
marry they told you who your friend or
who your foe is now you're an individual
it's up to you to figure this out so
it's no wonder that youth workers who I
think had their ear to the ground really
recognized that kids were becoming
obsessed with the relationship because
they're trying to negotiate it walking
into a big government institution filled
with other kids are trying to figure out
who who is my friend and who is it who
should I hang out with and who should
die where do I belong and where do I
work don't I and of course adolescence
or teenagehood just expands from
something from 8 o'clock to 3 o'clock
now you can't get away from it so
especially with social networking sites
you're a teenager forever I mean you
don't you don't get a break for me to
teenager you're always a teenager and
you're negotiating where you belong so
it's no wonder that we start talking
about the importance of relationships
during this time now let me push us a
little bit here to talk about this in
the sense of well what do we mean by
relationship I mean this was kind of my
own experience in my own ministry in
Southern California what are we really
talking about when we're talking about a
relationship it's interesting that
culturally we use this word relationship
a lot of different things like for
instance I would say I have a
relationship with Apple I love Apple I
love their products I love their phones
and other computers I actually rank
things important in my life my children
my computer my wife I mean these are
they're like the most important things
in my life I'm kidding I'm kidding
sort of but but I have a relationship
with him I love going to the Apple store
I love being with them but would we we
use that word relationship but it's kind
of qualitative distinction between the
relationship someone has with a product
in the relationship a mother has with
her newborn child and we use the word
relationship for both but there's an
inner reality that's different so what
do we mean when we're talking about
relationships with young people I often
think that the way we've talked about
relationships and had our relationship
focus and youth ministry is we've tended
to talk about relationships as for
personal influence in other words the
point of the relationship is to be the
best tool for doing youth ministry the
point of the relationship is to use it
to get somewhere else that the point of
the relationship is that I become your
friend so I can get you to go to church
or I become your friend so you see the
importance of church membership and you
stay in church after confirmation or I
become your friend so that you don't do
immoral things at the point of the
relationship is to serve as the best
tool to get somewhere else so it tends
to mean that there is a means to an end
but again the point of ministry isn't
the relationship itself the point of
ministry is to use the relationship to
get to some other objective some other
goal it has a youth worker your job
isn't really building relationships with
young people necessarily your job really
is to build the youth group or your job
really is to get kids converted or
confirmed that's really your job in the
relationship serves as the best tool to
get that done if that means that there
is a third thing involved but it's not
just you and the young person or the
adult in the young person that really
matters but there's a third thing
involved here and again what you're
really loyal to isn't necessarily the
young person but growth the youth group
or membership that's what you're
actually really loyal to I've been very
impacted by the theology Dietrich
Bonhoeffer an interesting thing in his
book sanctorum communal which was his
first book he actually says this really
profound line where he says there is
only I in you
there is no third thing Jesus Christ
meets us in the encounter between the I
in you in the mystery of our shared
relationship God becomes present there
is no third thing there is no third
thing we're trying to wield loyalty in
user relationship as leverage to get
somewhere else one of the major problems
with practicing relational ministry as
influences what fundamentally then
matters in what your job becomes is
getting kids to decide things getting
them to decide to come to church getting
them decide to go to camp getting them
to decide to go on the mission trip that
your job is to get them to decide things
to get them decide that Jesus is
important that your job really is to get
them to decide things I mean it is
really to do in some ways maybe this is
a little bit of a crass example but it's
to do an inception on them all out of
the movie Inception the Christopher
Nolan movie your job is to use the
relationship to implant new ideas to get
them to decide in a certain way now this
is the second time that I flew into the
Hartford Airport the first time I was
invited to go to a conference who's in
Hartford and there's this big ballroom
filled with with people and it was a
really unique conference because it was
a Lily funded project that just was
gonna release its findings and if you
know anything about lily and and been in
mainline congregations and schools you
know that lily has funded a lot of
research on the church in general but on
young people particularly and I've had
the privilege of being part of these so
I often tell people and you know who
Lily is they make depression medicine
and things like that
I tell people I've taken a lot of drug
money in my day so I was at one of these
and it was really unique because they
had academics in the room they had
publishers in the room but they had paid
youth people in the room but they also
had spent money to fly in volunteers who
were very committed to their churches
and so they were releasing these
findings it'd be you know they were
released a finding would come up on a
PowerPoint slide the researchers would
talk about how they came to this
conclusion and then there would be an
open mic and people from the conference
could stand up and talk about this so
number four something comes up that says
relationships are important so the
researchers talked about it and it's
open mic time and this young man gets up
he's probably in his late 20s early 30s
he's a volunteer in his youth ministry
and he says you know I get this I get
that relationships are really important
but he says you know what really
chips can also be really hurtful and he
told the story said you know when I was
in high school my parents were going
through an awful divorce like awful
awful divorce yelling and screaming
fighting lawyers calling he said it was
pure chaos at my house so that was this
weird kid very cerebral I love to read I
was just a weird kind of high school kid
and so I was at a coffee shop one day
and I found this book on Buddhist
meditation it was appealing to me
because all the chaos going on in my
family so I took it home and I started
to read it so my youth pastor was so
significant to me he found out through a
friend that I was reading this so he
took me out for coffee and he said yeah
and I know things are hard but I heard
you reading this Buddhist book why are
you doing that
so you know I'm doing it because of
things going on homes well don't do that
is it you know it's a false religion and
you know you don't need to read that
stuff you know you just don't do it and
so he went home Easter day listened to
his youth better he really trusted his
youth Bester went home and the chaos
began again so he picked up the book and
read it some more youth Bester found out
and this time confronted them again now
more forcefully he said listen it's my
job as your youth pastor to make sure
you're deciding for your faith now you
need to decide for your faith and so I
said he listened to him went home
read it again youth pastor found out
never called him again
and of course what happens with this
youth pastor I mean we can all critique
his theology here but what ultimately
happened is in the past oral practice
what this youth pastor saw is that was
his job to get kids to decide and if the
point is personal influence then we have
to face it kids that are hard to
influence you know cut him loose and
find someone it's easier kids who are
stubborn or who have certain forms of
suffering who can't be easily influenced
or up deep doubts and deep fears you
know at the end of the day your
objective is to build the youth group or
your objective is to get kids to know
certain things so that they can be good
Christian kids and you can feel good
about your ministry so cut them loose I
mean we're being a little crass here but
it plays I think under the surface of
this very idea that the point of the
relationship is to use it to influence
kids towards some end so like i stoled
you I had two I have two kids a
four-year-old and a seven-year-old and I
don't know what we did to these kids but
we passed out a terrible genetic disease
to them which is that they didn't sleep
until they're like 18 to 20 months see I
can always tell people who have lived
through it because your compassion just
spills from your eyes and then I can
tell you jerks we haven't had kids yet
because you're like
so who cares let me tell you if it
happens to you may God have mercy on
your soul because it suck when you're up
every hour and a half with a kid who's
crying or getting up so we you know this
is an Internet age so the great thing
about the Internet age is you can find
information on anything you know so the
downside is a lot of it is terrible but
you can find all this information so we
were just desperate people so we were
googling can't get my kids to sleep and
we were coming up with all this stuff
and then we were building I'm going to
kill my child please help me get this
kid to sleep but we stumbled across this
one and we were desperate now
so we stumbled across this one that came
from a very conservative perspective but
hey beggars can't be choosers here we
were ready for any hint to get our kids
to sleep and this Burton perspective
said that the way that you get your kids
asleep the way you get your kid to
actually learn to sleep is that the
minute you take your child home from the
hospital minute you take your newborn
baby home and you set her in her crib
and you walk away and she cries you
never go to her absolutely not
after all this perspective said your
child is sinful and if you give in when
she cries you give in to her sinful will
but if you go only on your schedule you
will bend her will towards obedience
even at 1 in 2 days old now we were
desperate people but not quite that
desperate but what's interesting is that
this perspective had a theological
assertion it based brokenness and
sinfulness fundamentally only in the
will and it was all about deciding so
now I mean the way they wanted us to
parent our kid was to bend her will
towards decision even when she was 1
years old but it really plays into a
relational Ministry of influence that
your job is to bend kids towards some
form of obedience maybe it's you know
not a conservative kind of understanding
obedience what it is to come to church
it is to be part of the congregation it
is to be a good moral kid I mean that is
fundamentally your job is to bend them
towards deciding so we did a terrible
parenting mistake when Maisie was about
nine months old
Owen was about two and a half which i
think is illegal in like ten states
which is having the baby monitor
switched to the wrong channel you know
so it's you think it's broadcasting
something but it's not broadcasting
anything so about two hours into this
nap and we had put her
sleep on the middle of our bed which you
do with infants you know and it was like
two hours my gosh this is an incredibly
long nap so I walked by the stairs and I
heard her screaming and now I'm
convinced like we you know she's just
months old we can break her you know we
have to do something about this and I'm
already starting to calculate all the
money I'm gonna have to spend and
counseling and things because I you know
left her crying on our bed so I get
yelled at my wife car is a car up Macy's
awake we got to go and so we just
totally forgot about the two-and-a-half
year old you know he can go play in the
street the other one is in danger here
we got to do something about about this
so we ran upstairs when we found her on
her bed and she are bed and she was
screaming I mean she was doing one of
those infant cries where her face was
all red and nothing comes out for like
four or five seconds it wasn't hey I'm
awake crying it was where are you bleep
at he believed people when I get you I'm
gonna kill you how can I trust the
universe if I can't trust you to come
you know all of this up so we're just
panicked as parents you know of a
newborn so we pick her up and we try to
sue their Maisie it's okay it's okay
it's okay
mommy daddy right here well as we were
coming up the stairs the
two-and-a-half-year-old followed us
climbing up the stairs and as we're
holding her over our bed he climbs up on
the bed and as we're soothing or Mazie
it's okay don't cry please don't cry ooh
it's okay
he starts touching her head gently and
kissing it in at this really sweet way
and then he says don't cry baby amazing
it's okay baby Maisy you just have hotus
now he has our attention and we look at
him say oh and what is hotus and he
looks at us matter-of-factly like how
can't you idiots know this you know and
he says Oh
notice is when you're all alone and
crying and there's no one there to be
with you and we said yeah I think of us
before I think I know what that is and
maybe the depth of the human condition
isn't that we're just big wills that
need to be bent towards something but
all of us whether we're nine months or
nine years old or 19 or 99 we know what
it's like to be all alone and crying and
needing someone just to be there with us
someone just to share our place and one
just to be with us maybe the depth of
the human condition is that we know what
it's like to have hotus this made up you
know two and a half-year-old word that
we know what that's like and in the
midst of practicing relation ministers
influences we tend that
kids in this point of being all alone
and needing someone to be there with
them we have other things we got to get
to we have other places we need to
direct them that we can't just attend to
their humanity that yearns for someone
to be there someone to hear them and to
see them in the midst of this now I also
think that the Incarnation this
confession we make that Jesus Christ is
the fullness of God that God in Jesus
Christ has entered into our world I
think that actually the Incarnation is
very little to do with influence at all
now in my family every Christmas Eve we
go over to my grandmother's house and
she's of Swedish descent so we every
Christmas Eve have to have Swedish
meatballs and if you've had them at IKEA
you have no idea how much better they
are than my grandma's just stick with
the IKEA Swedish meatball you just
wonder what century was it that the
Swedes discovered salt and pepper you
know I mean they're just this bland
please do not send that as you're
recording this to my grandmother so
every Christmas Eve we have to have our
Swedish meatballs and as Chris s
Christmas dinner is over we put the
dirty plates where I've only eaten half
of them and we put those up onto the
counter my grandma's terrible at Swedish
meatballs but she's great at Christmas
cookies so as the plates go up the
coffee starts brewing the Christmas
cookies come out and people grab cookies
and coffee and transition into her
living room into her couches and sofas
and actually as we do that my grandma
always disappears and she goes into a
back room and she comes back with a
cutout piece of newspaper or a story
that she had cut out of number of years
back and you've all heard the story it's
the Paul Harvey story about the birds so
my grandma sits down Andrea has to read
us the story it's a story about this man
who one Christmas Eve decides he's not
going to church he doesn't believe he's
not doing it and after all in his part
of the country it is a cold bitter cold
winter night Christmas Eve night and
he's not going to church so he watches
his family get all bundle up and head
off to church he grabs a book and a
blanket lays next to the fire has kind
of a laugh to himself on how much
smarter he's decided to spend his night
about halfway through his night he looks
out the window and there's these birds
on his lawn
these sparrows and he's read the weather
forecast and he knows it's gonna get
bitter cold it is gonna get really
bitter cold and he knows these birds
will not
survive unless something's done and so
they're just out there in his lawn
so he's filled with compassion so he
decides that he's gonna go out there
he's gonna save these birds I mean he
knows they're gonna die that there's no
way they're gonna make it through the
night and the last thing he wants on
Christmas morning is for his kids to
come down and see dead birds in the lawn
anyhow so he wants to do something for
these birds so ironically he has to go
and put his hat and coat and boots on
and he heads outside he knows he just
has got to get them through the night
get some shelters so he opens his barn
doors shed where he keeps his tools and
he decides if he can get his birds in
there that they'll be safe so he tries
to shoo them in but of course with every
shoe they jump the opposite way they
have no idea what he's trying to do here
so he tries again now with a gentler
voice but still it doesn't work they
jump the other way so now he's getting
desperate cuz it's getting colder even
as he's out there he knows he's got to
do something for these birds or they're
gonna die so he makes a trail of
breadcrumbs thinking that he can lure
them into the barn and they'll be safe
but they still won't follow him so now
he's getting desperate he knows
something's got to be done and
something's got to be done quick or
these birds are gonna die so he tries
one more time in desperation and
pleading with these birds to please get
into the barn to please get in the barn
and it still it doesn't work so now he's
thinking himself what can I do what
should I do and then he thinks if only
if only I could become a bird they
wouldn't be afraid of my voice and I
could lead them into the barn and they'd
be safe and just as he says that the
church bells ring he falls on his knees
and for the first time he understands
the meaning of Christmas and my grandma
wipes away one tear folds her paper
takes her cookie takes a bite sips her
coffee and leans back onto her sofa and
utter Christmas delight I sit in the
corner and I promise you I'm not cruel
enough to say it but I always think it
grandma it's a beautiful story
you can see why you like it so much but
it's not really the Incarnation the
confession of the church is not that we
need a God who becomes human enough to
get us in the barn to influence us in
one direction the confession of the
church is we need a God who becomes so
human that this God bears the dark cold
night with us all the way to hell and
back that this God is with us in the
midst of the utter cold night the
problem with practicing relational
ministry is influence is you only have
to be human enough with
people to get them to do what you want
them to do we probably all remember this
from our seminary days or maybe your
undergraduate days but you remember as
Christianity moved into the Hellenistic
Greek world that came into a certain
problem which was that all the Greeks
had gone to the same undergraduate
education there are very clever people
but they had one perspective that they
really held on to which was that matter
particularly the human body was bad in
that spirit was good this is why you
remember when Socrates is told you have
to die for corrupting the youth of
Athens and he has to take his poison
it's not the worst day for Socrates you
know it's like yeah it could have been
better but I get to escape the world of
the matter in the tomb of my body and
enter into the spirit world so you can
imagine as Christianity goes into this
Hellenistic Greek world their minds
almost blew up with this assertion that
God that this the early church was
asserting that God that the fullness of
God had come in taken on matter and not
just matter but the human body I mean
that's just disgusting you know how
could that be well of course the Greeks
were really clever people so they worked
their way around it and they said well
maybe it isn't that God actually took on
flesh in Jesus Christ maybe it's that
God appeared - in other words God Jesus
became a just a really great hologram
you know like obi-wan Kenobi in Star
Wars or something in the early church
wrestled with this and wrestled with
this in wrestled with this and finally
ruled it out as a heresy it was called
the heresy of docetism and they asserted
that we need a God in Jesus Christ who
doesn't just appear to become human but
that becomes fully human
the problem with practicing relational
ministry is influenced using our
relationships just to influence in
people is there's more than just a
little dose it is Amann our practice of
ministry you only have to be human
enough you only have to be with and for
young people enough to get them to do
what you want to do final point is that
the Trinity does cradle confession we
make that in God's self is this
relationship of Father Son and Holy
Spirit I mean it would be absurd for us
to imagine that in the inner life of God
self there's a relationship of influence
going on so if there's like a game of
Survivor going on the son and the father
are teamed up in an alliance to get the
spirit to do something that would be
just absurd we want to assume that we
assume that the relationship that exists
within God's self is something more
beautiful something more self giving
now as we go today those of you are with
us rest day you're gonna I just have to
confess this to you I watch way too much
TV and I watch really bad reality TV I
always say it's just for research
purposes that's really not but I'll just
keep telling you it's for research
purposes but I want to show you a clip
from a reality show and this just shows
you how much you need to pray for me it
is a reality show that only ran three
times before it was cancelled and I
watched all three now you don't need to
know any of this I just think this is
really funny maybe some of you saw this
this show is called God or the girl did
anyone see the show what it's about and
again you don't need to know any of this
I just think this is really funny it's
all about these men they're all men who
are in serious dating relationships like
they either have bought rings to get
engaged or they're gonna pick out rings
mean they're close to getting engaged
but they're also considering becoming
Catholic priests so they literally have
to choose god or the girl all right I
just tell you that so not only can you
pray for me but you can also pray for
the people in some room in Burbank
coming up with these ideas like hey you
know it'd be a good idea we should try
this so you don't really need to know
any of this but if you want to find the
show on the Internet you can find it but
what's happening in this in this
particular clip is one of these young
men is actually right now involved with
a college ministry and the college
ministry is getting ready to invite
young people back on a campus they're
coming back for a new semester and
they're having their leadership meeting
to decide how they're going to do
ministry this semester with these young
people and what I want you to do is
listen for a relational ministry of
influence and particularly listen to the
woman who's in charge who has reddish
blond hair and again see if you hear a
relational Ministry of influence
all the things that the world said made
me a success on the inside
it was emptiness
and a lot of people say yes and they
start coming when you take the first two
even three weeks on campus and just wind
up the women who are rushing the Greek
houses are moving in this weekend as a
recruitment is all next week put on your
most cheerful face this is the first
interaction that we're gonna have with
new students work it's why took this job
as a missionary was the first time when
I actually decided you know what God I'm
gonna give you a shot I'm not giving you
a chance because nothing else will be
working in my life when I hear about the
lifestyle that he was living in the
opportunities that he had and the paints
fact that he was receiving every month
I'm just I'm so impressed that he was
able to turn his back on that playing
sports was gotta have ice cream hanging
out on the door going wants to enter the
cafeteria and just win them over then
when I won their heart and even if
they're not that interested in the
diversity they're probably become at
least once just out of really loyalty to
me as a friend
so as measurement process goes seminary
is definitely winning I look at my work
as a missionary and and I realized that
there's still a point where I could go
back to the secular world I could go
back to something else and I can't
devote all of my time in the way that I
see priests doing that that's their life
and so it just gets me more excited all
right so what did you hear yeah there's
a language of win them over now I always
say this after I show this clip cuz I'm
afraid that this young woman is gonna be
in one of these rooms I'm at and then
she'll hurt me at some point but I mean
I've said these pretty much these same
exact things so I just say that as a
disclaimer but yeah I mean she says win
them over and how is she gonna win them
over
I scream and first beat and a smile yeah
I mean I I was somewhere in Texas and I
never I believe me I've seen this clip
millions of times it almost makes me
nauseous because I've done this
presentation so many times but somebody
finally said you know what I noticed is
that they say put on your smiles he said
you know the reason I remember that is
because when I worked at Walmart when I
was in high school before our shift
would start they would say put on your
smiles but yeah she says to win them
over with ice cream and frisbee no I'm
not against ice-cream frisbee
I actually well I like ice-cream frisbee
I can't throw it straight but that's
about my own issue but what is she I
mean she says have ice-cream with them
play frisbee with them and then at least
once out of loyalty to me they're going
to come to Bible study that in some ways
that's kind of in youth ministry one on
one that you use your relationship as
this kind of context to build a
connection so that they're receptive for
you to say something to win them over I
get it but let's be honest none of us
would stand for that in our own lives in
our own adult lives somebody from work
said hey can I take you up for a drink
after work
he said sure that'd be great and you got
halfway through the drink I said well
really the reason I asked you here
because my my my mic partner and I are
in this great pyramid scheme and we can
get you in at the bottom we would be
incredibly frustrated we think I thought
you wanted to know me I thought you were
you're in this to get to know me and now
this is a bait and switch here and so
often I think in the context to youth
ministry because these are young people
who are making decisions and and we feel
like we have to somehow influence them
in the right way so often we use our
relationships as a way to bait them over
to something else so we have ice cream
with them play frisbee with them or
maybe something more sophisticated in
your case but the point is to use that
to get somewhere else
now I'm not like I said I'm not against
ice cream I'm not a good frisbee but I
actually want someone to have ice cream
with me or play frisbee with me because
I want to know me because they want to
get to know me and I want and therefore
I want to get to know them which maybe
means for them to confess the gospel and
its depth but I want them to actually
know me and I think this is the problem
with relational ministry as the point to
influence is that it's really not about
the humanity of the young person it's
really about where you get them and I
think the gospel is too beautiful and
our humanity is too beautiful and warped
to assume that it can be encompassed and
having ice cream and playing frisbee to
get kids to do what we want them to do
so if I've convinced you even just a
little bit that there might be a problem
with practicing relational ministry of
as influence what might be another
perspective especially if relationships
are so important as that kind of
cultural piece at the beginning tried to
make the assertion of well maybe the
point of our relationships in youth
ministry our point of our relationships
and ministry in general isn't for
influence but actually for play sharing
and play sharing is actually a word I've
stolen from Dietrich Bonhoeffer and vana
for says in his ethics he says just as a
good politician is for her people a good
teacher is for his students and a good
father is for his children
so Jesus Christ is for us Jesus Christ
shares our place Jesus Christ is found
with and for us that Jesus Christ shares
our place so to practice relational
ministry as play sharing means that the
relationship isn't the best tool for
ministry it is the ministry itself that
the confession is that God shows up that
the event of God's very presence happens
in the sharing of our humanity and in
the seeing in being with and for as
Jesus Christ is with and for us that the
relationship is it that the relationship
is the point that Miss that ministry
happens inside the mystery of encounter
each other's humanity and confessing God
and confessing Jesus Christ not outside
it but within it itself so it then means
to actually stand in for young people
that the point of our ministries with
young people is actually to stand in for
them to be with and for them just as
Jesus Christ is with and for us asbahna
forces radically in his little book
Christ the center he says Jesus Christ
is ontologically in the very essence of
who Jesus Christ is it cannot be
separated Jesus Christ is ontologically
for you
beside you with you what you do unto
your neighbor you do unto Jesus Christ I
love Matthew 25 because Jesus Christ is
their Lord Lord when did we see you what
you did unto the other you did unto me
when you shared in the life of the other
you shared in the very life of Jesus
Christ so it means to stand in for then
means that the full person that the full
humanity the young person matters not
just their decision but their full
humanity is what's important so I had a
student who called me a few months after
he had started a job and he said you
know I took all your classes and thank
you very much because you've earned my
life so they're always my favorite calls
you know and he says I got to tell you
this story said I just got this job at
this church and it was one of these
churches that had this sacred thing on
the calendar that you had to do and at
this church it was a senior ski trip you
had to be a senior to go on a senior in
high school to go on it but it was a ski
trip well they also had in their youth
group and in their ministry this young
woman who suffered from bipolar
depression
and when often when she was moving from
up to down she would lash out and was
very hard for anyone to be around her
well he had looked at the roster people
would sign up on the ski trip and oh she
hadn't signed up and so he figured you
know this is her last shot you only get
to go when you're a senior so he reached
out to her and he called her invited her
to come well sure enough she signed up
to go soon as her name appeared on the
roster parents and kids started to say
things like you know passive-aggressive
things like I don't know if this is a
good idea I hope she doesn't have to
stay in my cabin well sure enough they
take her on the ski trip they take the
group on the ski trip she's in a cabin
with four other high school seniors in
an adult leader
she has an episode and it's much less
than a good experience for all these
young women get everyone home unload the
bus clean the bus my student is on his
way home and his cell phone is about to
explode parents calling sets up a
meeting with them on the next Monday
they the parents get in there and they
berate him how dare you what bad
judgment how could you bring her along
our daughters have been waiting to go on
this trip since they were in eighth
grade and now you've learned it for them
and just berating and berating and
ringing finally one of the father stands
up gets right in his face and says
listen listen I get it
this is a church people are struggling
should be here I get it but you need to
tell me right now she's been part of
this ministry forever you've been
running this ministry for months you
need to tell me right now how is she
getting better what way she's getting
better she has a right to be here I get
about what is happening to get her
better now the truth is a practicing
relational ministry as influence that is
your job get her better that's your job
I don't know how you do that you talk to
most clinical psychologists they'll tell
you I don't know I don't know how you do
that medication can help but I don't
know how you do it maybe the point of
ministry isn't to get her better to get
her over it but to actually join her in
it that the confession of Jesus Christ
that the fullness of our ministry is to
communicate to her that even when it
gets its darkest she's not alone even
when she feels alone she that we are
with and for her and that we confess and
witness in our presence that Jesus
Christ is with her and for her in the
darkest of situations at the point of
ministry is to be with in the confession
of Jesus Christ if that means that to
practice relational ministry as placer
means to actually suffer
with to actually suffer with young
people to suffer their questions to
suffer their experience the Pratt the
problem with the practicing relation
ministries influence they can't suffer
if you've ever had an experience of
suffering which I would imagine all of
us in this room have had one you know
that there is one truth to suffering
which is that it demands attention to
the experience no one likes to hear
it'll be better or God's using this for
the best we demand that people just tend
to our experience now in the problem
with influences you have other fish to
fry you have other things to get done
you can't just attend to the humanity of
a young person before us but I think
there's something central in the gospel
of joining and suffering at least a
nepali an element that we join and
shared suffering becomes the witness to
something new to God taking what's dead
in bringing life out of it that we share
and suffering as a way to bring forth
the new humanity the new creation that
something is bound when when we share in
each other suffering in a deep way
fourth point is its ethical and by
ethical I mean it shares in young
people's deepest doubts and deepest
fears and maybe even shares them as a
very curriculum of doing youth ministry
so my son is my job in my house to put
my son Owen to sleep which Owen always
has his deepest questions right at that
time and I can never tell if they're
really questions or the displays to stay
up later and he's this really great
little existential philosopher and
theologian who asked these really deep
questions and so one night I was putting
him to bed and he asked me this
incredibly deep question you have to
remember once Owen gets to bet I can do
important things with my life
which means watch hours and hours of
terrible television and so I'm putting
Owen to bed this night and he turns and
he looks at me
and his brow is kind of wrinkled and
he's in deep contemplation and he looks
at me he says dad I have a question so
alright you know let's go get to it Real
Housewives of Orange County are on right
now let's go kid
and he he looks at me and says daddy
will death will death ever fall in love
will death ever fall in love now you
have to understand where this comes from
that I had decided at some point that I
didn't want to raise this kid around
easy moral categories or as
you know are you a good bore boy or are
you a bad boy it seems too simplistic
you know like when you're mean you're
bad you know it just it didn't seem to
work and after all the biblical
narrative seems a little bit more
complicated than that
for instance we hear the story of
Jericho that despised going to Jericho
the woman hides them in the apartment
gets a knock on the door and says have
you seen any spies and she just flat-out
lies to him spies are you what are spies
can you explain this to me should be
quiet you know she just can flat-out
lies to them and then we're told she has
done the will of the Lord so there's
something a little bit more complicated
in the biblical text and maybe it rests
on more of an ethic of do you serve life
or do you serve death do you serve the
god of life or do you sort of death so I
decided that I was gonna raise my son
along these ethical lines so when he was
mean to his mommy or to his sister I
would say Owen in this house we serve
life and not death or Owen we don't do
that in this house it is about life and
not death all right I get it was a [ __ ]
a bit much for one and a half year old
but he actually got it what one day we
were on a walk and he tripped over the
raised sidewalk and fell and kind of
skinned his knee and we ran up to him
and said Owen Owen are you all right and
he lifted up his pant leg and it was a
little red and blood he said yeah I'm
fine but death made me bleed so he got
this so I'm putting him to bed and he
turns to me and he says daddy will death
ever fall in love not one of my best
parenting moments ever because I turned
to him talked him in again and said yes
Owen someday death will fall in love and
when it falls in love it'll destroy
death and death will be no more now good
night go to sleep and don't you dare
call me again not one of my best
parenting moments but it incredibly for
a fun question
maybe the question the whole universe
rests on which is what's stronger life
or death I feel so much possibility
inside of me and yet find myself bumping
up against nothing is what wins what is
my lifetime and why do I live it anyhow
I mean the great unbelievable pleasure
and blessing of you doing what you do is
you actually get to wrestle with young
people around these questions now I get
it my kids brilliant I know that
but my guess is if my four-year-old asks
those questions but surely a 14-year old
does surely a 19-year old us maybe a 35
year old used to until they've been
socialized out of asking those questions
but this is the great blessing that
these young people are to the church is
that they ask these questions will death
ever fall in love and the rest of us
gets so caught up in to how we're gonna
pay the mortgage what are we what's
gonna happen if the boiler breaks what's
gonna happen if it snows who's gonna
shovel it we get so involved in
governing this institution that we need
young people in our churches not because
they're the Church of tomorrow that's
kind of you know not to be crass but
that's kind of shitty you know we don't
need them because they're the Church of
tomorrow
we need them cuz we need their
theological voice now because they say
will death ever fall in love what is a
lifetime and why do we live it what you
get to do I know we don't get paid very
well I know we're always overlooked but
what incredible privilege then you get
to just wrestle with these questions
with young people and to wrestle
sometimes with questions that I have no
answer but is the very mystery of God's
Act
what is stronger life or death is there
a possibility is God moving in the midst
of my nothing is to bring something new
we get to wrestle with them what an
incredible incredible privilege final
two points the Incarnation I think is
the fullest picture we have of God who
shares our place through death all the
way to hell and back that God shares our
place through our darkest night and that
the Trinity I think is this beautiful
picture of self giving love within the
Father Son and Holy Spirit let me pray
for us
God thank you for these people and may
you remind them even now the blessing
they are to your church we pray that you
would encourage them and fill them so
that they might continue and I said this
so important ministry we thank you for
your call and pray that we might be
brave to be with young people trusting
that when we are that you will move God
so bless us and bless these people amen
thanks you guys
you